and last month journalists revealed an
alleged cia plot to kidnap or even kill
julian assange many of those who read it
must have thought
wow if the mightiest of spy agencies was
so keen to get rid of the whistleblower
it's really a miracle he's still alive
if the claims from september's report
are true it just shows how much he's
loathed by anyone in charge in d.c
for his partner though and other
prominent activists it served as another
chance to convince the rest of the world
what washington's real intentions are
when it comes to assange
this is a game changer going into the
appeal because it shows the true nature
the true origins the true criminality of
the us actions against julian
now reports that the cia considered
kidnapping or killing assange have cast
even more doubt on the reliability of
u.s promises and further expose the
political motivation behind this case
a quick reminder of what was revealed in
september interviews with an entire team
of former trump officials suggested
senior members of the administration
supposedly requested options for killing
assange one of these alleged options
included engaging in a shootout in the
streets of london if you read all the
gory details you'll be amazed by how
hollywood it all is that was back in
2017 when wikileaks published a damning
investigation into cia hacking tools
this is just how embarrassing things got
for the u.s system it's the point at
which you'd expect the people and
organizations involved to react or
rather fail to react by saying
no comment but mike pompeo did
they should all be prosecuted for
speaking about classified activity
inside the central intelligence agency
maybe they didn't maybe issac just made
it up but you should know i take
seriously my responsibilities to protect
that information this can be seen as
pompeo's confirmation of the assange
kidnap or kill story why else would you
want to prosecute those sources speaking
about classified activity only a few
months ago an icelandic news outlet
reported on some eye-opening testimonies
by a key witness in the u.s indictment
against the wikileaks founder very
embarrassing for the u.s justice system
too if true the iceland national
admitted that almost all of what he said
while being questioned by the fbi
consisted of lies proffered in exchange
for immunity from american prosecution
[Music]
this activity was said to include
attempts to hack into the computers of
members of parliament and record their
conversations in fact thorson now admits
to stunned in that assange never asked
him to hack or access phone recordings
of mps
[Music]
more deceptive language emerges in the
aforementioned judgments where it states
assange used the unauthorized access
given to him by a source to access a
government website of iceland used to
track police vehicles
[Music]
in reaction to that edward snowden said
that it was i'm quoting the end of the
case against julian assange
wishful thinking edward if only for once
someone in the obama trump or the biden
administration gave a damn about what
you've been saying or what's the leading
press freedom activists have been
sounding the alarm about
hypocrisy first and foremost
it is a damning indictment that nearly
20 years on virtually no one responsible
for alleged u.s war crimes committed in
the course of the afghanistan and iraq
wars has been held accountable let alone
prosecuted and yet a publisher who
exposed such crimes is potentially
facing a lifetime in jail
right by the looks of it be it new faces
in the white house in the administration
or not so new or outright old
forget even thinking about the idea of
any of them showing mercy for julian
assange